hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen zu einem video aus los
angeles ich hab mir gedacht ich
beantworte ja oft viele von ich klatsche
zeit so häufig im video sieht weiß nicht
wieso ich das mache ich beantworte leid
dass er dir oft fragen in videos wenn
ihr mir videos schicken mir fragen
stellt in videoform und ich weiß nicht
ob video gesagt haben mach ich in
letzter zeit relativ häufig auf meinem
kanal und ich habe mir gedacht warum
mache ich das nicht einfach mal wenn ich
in der nähe bin ist toll wir denken
wahrscheinlich wie sehe ich den aus
dieser position wenn im hintergrund so
eine krasse landschaft durch das einfach
mal anhalt habe schön ist dass die
landschaft ist zwar noch so schön
allerdings wenn ich mich davor stelle
seht ihr schon dass ich dunkel bin und
die landschaft hell und das ist datiert
das licht ist halt viel besser wenn es
so ist und im video soll das tobias in
videos ist halt besser wenn das licht
gut ist deswegen werde ich die kamera
einfach ihr plätzchen und mich hier
hinsetzen und dann haben wir fangen aber
auch schon direkt an mit der erste frage
tomatensaft gericht so was sagen das ist
tatsächlich in letzter zeit so dass 90
prozent der sachen die mir eingesendet
wurden ist einfach nur um viele wirklich
nur die sachen raus suche wo tomaten
satz gesagt wird es aber nicht so es
kommt wirklich 90 prozent ist einfach
hin ist um ein bild was ist denn das
tomatensaft
gucken wir jetzt war ob es auch
irgendwelche richtigen fragen gibt weil
ich wollte wirklich dieses mal wirklich
coole fragen beantworten weil ich dachte
mir okay ist es so professionell ich hab
sonne guckt euch diesen hintergrund ein
alter das ich muss einfach richtige
fragen jetzt beantworten viele denken
wahrscheinlich dass es eine tapete ist
aber ja ist eine scheibe vor aber es ist
wirklich echt sind meine fingerabdrücke
trinkl übrigens gerade das allererste
mal in meinem leben dieses feature motto
das ist kein place bin ich mache das
immer rechts ranfahren wenzel es ist
aber es stinkt normales wasser alter was
feiern dass alle so wir fangen jetzt
einfach mal aus der ersten frage kamera
hätten wäre ich doch ganz schön am
schalter habe die flasche umgeworfen
fenster angebracht luca bringst du
eigentlich noch bettwäsche heraus er
erstmal sehr cool dass du bei der frage
und deine füße gefilmt hast das ist ich
werde noch bettwäsche rausbringen
allerdings habe ich keinen bock darauf
jetzt einfach zu sagen hey mich haben
schon so viele bettwäsche hersteller
angeschrieben das ist ja echt umfasst
allerdings habe ich keinen bock zu sagen
ja klar produziert bettwäsche und die
ist scheiße nach dabei man kennt da drin
und man kennt ihn wie einen drittel oder
bei mir jetzt ist ein zehntel des tages
verbringe ich ca aber mein pennt halter
drin und deswegen muss es sein so ein
shirt das kann man einfach so wenn man
sagt dass der schalter ist es hat nicht
an meinen tag aber eine bettwäsche
deswegen will ich dass es perfekt wird
deswegen dauert das denke ich noch ein
bisschen arbeit wird kommen weil ich
finde gerade dieses mal die salami auf
der bettwäsche macht sich richtig gut
hanno luca ich bin auch ein kollege und
würde gerne zu euch also meldet euch
doch mal
ansonsten bin ich echt enttäuscht als
ich das gesehen dass ich mir nur so
welche ausmaße nimmt das alles alle
alter wir werden auch so viele videos
zugesandt wo leute auch auf ihre flasche
so mies drauf geklebt haben und sich
stofftiere gekauft haben und da die
benannten haben und alles aller kill
your base du wer ich so dumm bin müsste
dass ich auch machen ich finds ultra
krass mir wurden auch schon so viele
ukulelen zugesendet die auch irgendwie
jetzt irgendwie nahm ich weiß gar nicht
wie entstand das alles mit der ukulele
ich finde auf jeden fall ultra cool dass
diese
colina oder wer auch immer das sein soll
dass sie gemacht wurde
ich werde bei dem video days sein und
noch bei mehreren sachen da könnt ihr
mir die auf jeden fall geben und alter
wenn ich die noch hätte das wäre krass
dann würde ich glaube ich echt eine soap
anfang mit den ganzen sachen die da bei
mir brauchen damit sind warum stehen
hierfür frage raus okay ich war
tatsächlich schon ein paar mal besoffen
ist er kein geheimnis ich trinke alkohol
nicht dass ich abhängig bin dabei auf
einer party trinkt man alkohol irgendwie
ja ich habe respekt vor allen leuten die
keinen alkohol trinken aber ich finde
wenn ich dann irgendwie weißen mine
stößt dann halt einfach anders ist ich
habe scheißegal was wir nicht
rechtfertigen ich darf ja ich jedenfalls
war ich schon ein paar mal echt total
betrunken und das krasseste war
irgendwie auf sonder auf seiner
abschluss links wo man halt wirklich
morgens früh angefangen hat und abends
dann echt ging es dann so immer weiter
und das war s hat sonne geschienen das
war echt so wo ich mir gesagt haben okay
jetzt an ihrer tasche bayern war dort
mal so richtig letztendlich habe ich mir
den fuß verstaucht und mehrere
prellungen zugezogen
danach habe ich nicht mehr laufen konnte
aber das ist der moment wo ich mir
gesagt okay jetzt kenne ich meine grenze
unterschied sich nicht mehr darüber
hinaus ich finde es erstmal weiß dass
ihr meinen merge tragt das ist echt
ultra cool es ist echt wenn ich sage ich
schicke mir fragen zu hat jeder zweite
irgendwie ein rudi oder den chart von
jana 2 das ist so als wäre so eine
familie
ich mag bratwurst in form von currywurst
ja ich bin doch noch unternommen
ich finde bratwurst an sich ist recht
trocken aber ich bin wenn es in form von
einer currywurst ist oder so geht's
ultra klarkommen wenn ich komplett
gerade hier setzte er okay dann sieht
man mich trotzdem wenn es nichts anderes
zu essen gerne würde ich auch bratwurst
nehmen weil ich es nie die enden von dem
bratwürstchen ich finde das irgendwie
hast du dieses scheiß egal
guckt euch einfach mal diese aussage
okay ich sage ich habe mich ich weiß ich
hab euch die aus nicht schon gezeigt
aber es ist ja so
toll man es ist ja nicht mehr schön warm
stinkt du eigentlich so ich sehe das
nicht mehr rein das ist schon
ich weiß nicht wieso ich so stinken die
dusche ich jeden tag und wir waren heute
schon 37 waren schwimmen trainieren die
geduscht und jetzt in die video
aufgegeben steigern mitglieder
dann nämlich per fähre und den habe ich
weiß nicht wieso ich denke ich glaube es
liegt in meiner natur dass ich hatte
eigentlich mit youtube auf höheren alter
so eine scheiße was ich mache habe ich
für eine woche eingestellt von dir jetzt
jetzt nicht um die frage richtig zu
beantworten dann kontaktieren besten
holly match also geht auf luca - shop.de
und kriegt da ich auch kontakt und
sondern kannst ja sagen ihr euch pro
woche stellen wenn ich das mal
beantworten sollte würde ich einfach
sagen wenn du wirklich vor einer woche
gestellt hat war es ja wahrscheinlich
dann so um den dreh wo sie 20 prozent
gab mit luca 20 mit dem coach probiert
es nicht mehr der kopf funktioniert
nicht mehr allerdings haben da so viele
leute wieder beständen es war alles
wieder ausverkauft also 99 prozent
glaube ich dass wir wirklich nicht
hinterherkommen alter ihr seid krass was
bestellt dann geht es ist irre ich
bekomme nicht da hinterher es ist bittet
geduldig vielleicht ist das ja schon da
aber seien kontaktiert weil genauere
sache bezüglich lieferungen zu blöd für
mein schönstes erlebnis ich definitiv
ich definiere viele sachen als sehr
schön und ich will dich sagen dass alle
ihre sachen mein schönstes erlebnis war
weil sonst meine geburt einfach ihm ein
schöneres erlebnis gibt es ja nicht es
ist halt gerade unglaublich cool so wir
sind in der regel schönes wetter wir
haben
ich zeig doch mal die aus
aber ich würde jetzt sagen schönstes
erlebnis
ich glaube wenn ich jetzt etwas schönes
sage sind andere leute die wahren
erlebnis dabei war traurig turbulent war
cool sommer finde ich immer cool meiner
geburt war groß als es erstmal new york
war krass ey gerade ist cool so falls
ihr euch fragt wieso ich eigentlich hier
bin in l e das ist weil ich ein grab
wurde zu der premiere von natural born
praxis es ist so ein film von youtube
race geht ich packe man trailer eine
beschreibung jedenfalls freue ich mich
da hart drauf da will ich auf jeden fall
heute abend und das wird krass weil das
ist so als einzige premiere als ich
werde auch einen blog reinpacken jetzt
kommt denn wenn ich wieder zu hause bin
kommt ja einen blog über die komplette
reise new york alles zusammen da wartet
dann noch genaueres aber der trailer ist
erst meine beschreibung dazu nächste
frage
ich hatte damals raus hier
das hieß krümmel das einen löwenkopf
zwergkaninchen das haben dann aber
abgegeben werden zwei und das anders
gestorben
tragische story ich hatte lange zeit
überlegt eine schildkröte zu holen aber
der schule selbst nichts bevor man was
hat so die witzige wohin und zehn jahre
später sind dann zehn meter gelaufen
oder so ich werde definitiv später im
bund holen aber am liebsten rund gegen
den hass geht er sein eigenes leben hat
so ich sagte 'ja das mal raus spazieren
dann einfach keinen bock oder so und
dann will ich penne dann packt er
irgendwohin oder so dass wir ganz nice
so dass er sein eigenes seinen kopf hat
aber ich habe eigentlich mehr oder
weniger keine lust darauf aus zu haben
weil ich habe keine lust darauf an
richtige bindung dazu aufzubauen weil
wenn dann immer schrecklich ist mit dem
tier passiert dass man all unserer
traurig eigentlich nicht ich glaube
steht niemandem höheren verlust zu
verkaufen
ich weiß nicht wie oft ich in diesem
video schon geklappt hat aber es gibt
viele sachen wo ich mir wieder denkt oh
wow wie ihr rausholt cockpit ausschuss
zur letzten frage meine ich denke er
nicht an alle die das ist ja total viele
ich habe eine schwester
aber ich denke er nicht diese nicht in
diesem ganzen youtube filmen drin und
ich will meine familie eigentlich
komplett raushalten es gibt einige
youtuber die alle familienmitglieder in
ihrer familie ihnen die videos damit
machen soweit ich weiss nicht ihr die
hoffentlich davon hier klickst du dass
man einen titel schreibt dass meine
schwester video mit meiner mutter das
ist mein opa ist nicht so hart drauf so
ich will meine familie eigentlich
größtenteils raushalten so mit freunden
gern mal hier dass es zu gast die
kavallerie weise um die frage zu
beantworten meine dummheit zu beenden er
ich denke er nicht tut mir leid wenn
euch das video gefallen hat wie ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen es ist alles
sehr sporadisch jetzt gewesen weil wir
jetzt natürlich gerade hinreisen ich
werde irgendwie versuchen wir auf dem
laptop zu schneiden und ich hasse es am
laptop zu schneiden
wir sehen uns worauf wir sehen uns
wieder in einem video morgen an einem
gaming video übermorgen bei minecraft
und irgendwann danach die woche kommt
dann der block aus new york das heißt
wenn ihr sehen wollt wieso ich hier bin
und ich schon weiß ich jetzt hier rein